tu devrais rougir c'est tout ce que tu n'es pas
pourquoi de toute façon
je rêvais quand j'étais enfant j'ai vu ces
images de ce terrain immense et complexe et
j'espérais qu'un jour je pourrais voir que
non vient de sortir en français
beaucoup d'amis l'ont mentionné  que ce
livre était entièrement mon allié
ils ont dit ce focus pour toi encore jeune,
enlève-toi si c'est un peu brouillon c'est comme la
vie c'était un dialogue non-stop c'était une
merveilleuse façon de comprendre le
personnage c'est l'histoire d'un jeune homme
qui est envoyé  en Mongolie, il ne sait même pas
où il est et adore la
différence adore ces gens à travers
le pays
ce roman est une convergence de plusieurs
de mes scènes clés
ou de la musique d'amour